moore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les années 80 une époque fantastique
pour l'informatique très ancienne pour
vous situer à peu près il n'y avait pas
de wifi et pas de mp3 c'est vous dire
comme c'est loin à l'époque je fus
pirates ont échangé les logiciels sur
des supports numériques qu'on appelait
disquettes
pendant que nos frères à coeur commencé
à s'introduire sur des systèmes
d'information 23 avril 1989 une superbe
journée un soleil illumine le parmesan
une journée aller se promener en bon
geek je me suis levé tôt pour pouvoir
faire de l'informatique le matin et
essayer d'aller se stabilise et l'après
midi le téléphone sonne je cours je
décroche quand soudain je reconnais la
voix d'assaut il ne doit pas appelé
c'est la règle il ne doit jamais appelé
on ne s'appelle pas arnaud arnaud arnaud
arnaud j'ai merdé
arnaud ils savent que tu as les plans je
suis désolé fais gaffe il raccroche pas
ni complète
je ne comprends pas de quelle plus
tarder à l'époque on échange des
disquettes comme d'autres échanges des
timbres et moi mon rêve c'est de venir
soit peur qu'est-ce que ça qu'un soi
peur
le soin peur est celui qui distribue le
plus rapidement possible au plus grand
nombre les logiciels qui sont craqué par
le tracker le cracker c'est celui qui da
ont levé la protection du logiciel est
il des pendus suply tout cela est
organisé en réseau et pour en faire
partie
il faut être très bon a dog et
d'humanité je retourne à mes copies et
puis quand c'est fini au bout d'une
petite demi heure je commence à faire
mes petits paquets avec du scotch pour
renforcer les enveloppe en kraft pour
que ça passe bien le voyage
le téléphone sonne à nouveau jeu court
ça doit être maman ultime appel pour que
je mette à chauffer le four pour me dis
je décroche
bonjour eldar me lance une voix froide
mon interlocuteur m'explique qu'il sait
que j'ai les plans et qu'il veut me les
acheter
le problème c'est que chez les pirates
on ne vend pas c'est la règle ça pour le
fun pas pour le profit on ne vend pas
c'est comme ça pourtant mon
interlocuteur agi avec méthode
ces mots se place comme des pièces aux
échecs il insiste il insiste pour
m'acheter ces fameux plans
je sais pas quel où sont ces plantes
qu'elles sont faibles
c'est compliqué
pourtant il insiste et il insiste
toujours et moi je veux pas céder je
veux passionné je veux pas céder
et pourtant il continue il insiste sa
supériorité intellectuelle me tétanise
mais je continue à résister je ne
vendrai pas quand soudain ils changent
du tout au tout dans son discours il
m'explique faire partie de l'équipe de
développement du projet et que si je
viens à distribuer ces blancs ils
perdront tout leur investissement en
fils d'entrepreneur
nul mieux que moi peut comprendre jamais
jeunes distribuerait ses plans parole
d'homme je ne distribuerait pas ses
plans dans les dix minutes les plans
sont retrouvés est effacée sans le
savoir je viens de rentrer par une
petite porte dérobée dans l'univers
hackers dont le code est déjà dans mon
adn mais surtout qui m'accompagnera tout
au long de ma vie professionnelle et qui
développera chez moi une appétence pour
les faits science digital alors qu'est
ce que c'est que la culture hacker pour
moi la culture hacker pour moi c'est
l'art de l'astuce c'est comme ça que
l'homme a trouvé le feu l'outil la roue
et c'est en les partageant qu'il a fait
progresser l'humanité
alors oui nous sommes diabolisé mais qui
regardent ce qu'a apporté la culture
hacker au monde le mot ac apparaît om
haïti
un club de modélisme ferroviaire il est
utilisé quand on fait une connexion
ingénieuse entre deux relais pour les
petits trains d'où l'expression qui
viendra par la suite à coeur ensuite
apparaîtra la génération teffri casse le
captain crunch découvrira une méthode
pour ne plus payer le téléphone avec un
sifflet deux jeunes étudiants de steve à
l'époque à l'université améliore la
technique nomme le boîtier blue box
elles vendent sur leur campus pour se
faire de l'argent par la suite ils
monteront une petite entreprise du nom
de pommes plus proche de nous le chaos
computer club l'organisation de hackers
la plus influente d'europe
présidée actuellement par une femme
étudie les possibilités et les risques
pour la société de la technologie qui
ont été selon vous les premiers lanceurs
d'alert sur les risques pour votre vie
privée et sur la voracité des
mastodontes de la donner ces fameux gars
femmes l'éthique à coeur elle est
définit par steven levy en 1984 à
l'époque il est journaliste à rolling
stones et newsweek
il définit les tic à coeur en six points
six billets
l'ordinateur doit être accessible à tous
par contre il faudra peut-être faire des
efforts il est pour une information
libre
c'est ce qui permet de faire l'open
source par exemple et l'open data dont
on parle
plus récemment il est pour la
décentralisation et que le mouvement
travaille à la décentralisation
un hacker doit être jugé sur son hack
nom de fu critères info critère peut
être à ses yeux une ethnie un diplôme un
rang social ou le sexe logique arrêt
beauté peuvent être créés avec un
ordinateur les ordinateurs peuvent
changer améliorer la vie en 1990 les
hackers créé l'electronic frontier
foundation qui a pour vocation de
protéger les libertés civiles sur
internet en 1990 96 pardon john barlow
un des fondateurs de le f f rédige à
davos
la déclaration d'indépendance dû
cyberespace qu'il conclut par ces mots
nous créons une civilisation de l'esprit
dans le cyberespace
puisse-t-elle être plus humaine et plus
juste que le monde issu de vos
gouvernements léonard de vinci
considéré par certains comme le premier
des hackers mort de sa belle mort à 67
ans donc d'une mort naturelle
le deuxième personnage et alan turing la
personne qui craqua le code allemand son
crime
à l'époque était sa préférence sexuelle
il finit par se suicider à l'âge de 41
ans
aaron parts
son crime en 2013 être un activiste
citoyen il se suicida à 26 ans n'est-il
pas temps de changer notre regard sur
les hackers bienveillant si nous ne
voulons pas que l'histoire nous jugent
trop durement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]